[Music]
who you are smooth just doing my beauty
what what did I say come on tell me
you're in just a little bit sensitive
for the last time I don't want to buy a
timeshare come on man it's high five you
know me I'm a favorite it's gotta be
some sort of mistake I mean look at me
I'm an attractive hand giving up i5o
lady he's a knucklehead literally look
at him I can look like that what Center
an emoji huh okay
any cool welcome to the secret world
inside your phone we're emojis like me
work and live here each of us does one
thing and we have to nail it every time
incoming text we are go for met me
[Music]
what is that I've got to get this phone
fixed this has never happened before
and now alex has made an appointment to
wipe out his phone it's delete white oh
you're not gonna run away from this I
made a mistake but I'm gonna fix it I
think we can make things right we just
have to go to a place where no emoji has
gone before the cloud I know a shortcut
there's math but no one's ever left our
city I'm Nessen softer Oh
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever I've never eaten another piece of
candy again
high five don't do it don't you do it
it's already been in there once you need
to get the master password access
tonight this might take a while what
access tonight we're gonna have some
dance our way out
everybody could dance see
[Music]